When we stand on
a bathroom scale,
we learn, for better
or worse, our weight.
In more precise terms, the
scale quantifies our mass.
All matter in the visible
universe has mass.
It's what governs the movement
of planets, stars and galaxies
through the force of gravity.
And all matter everywhere is
structured in the same way.
The standard model of physics,
developed more than 50 years
ago, explains this structure
in terms of quarks, gluons,
and their interactions.
These particles,
interacting together,
make up protons and
neutrons, which,
along with electrons, in turn
make up more familiar atoms.
But this creates a question.
The mass of quarks
inside a proton
is much less than that
of the proton itself.
And gluons have no mass at all.
How is this possible?
In order to find
some answers, we
have to dive into the
world inside the proton.
But this presents a challenge.
Protons are made up of chaotic
bundles of quarks and gluons
moving at near light
speed, interacting
and annihilating each other.
It has always seemed
nearly impossible to create
an accurate picture
of this world.
But a new collaborative
project is visualizing
the fundamental
structure of the proton
based on original research
and sophisticated animation.
Visualization has been a
powerful tool for science
for the last three decades.
The Hubble Space Telescope
has produced stunning images
that have transformed how people
everywhere view the universe.
Now, a startling new view
of the subatomic world
is also within reach.
Physicists from MIT
and Jefferson Lab
are working with a group of
animators and documentary
filmmakers to both create a
more accurate visualization
of the structure of the
proton and to document
the collaboration
between science
and the arts that
drives this work.
The goal is to provide
a more complete view
of subatomic structures
that has the potential
to change how people think about
the nature of matter itself.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I've created the three
quarks as points of light,
and I've given them each
a chromodynamic color.
And I've set it up so they
trade colors between each other
the whole time.
Yeah.
They're also moving in a way
where they're jumping around.
No, I think this was very, very
good, the way you did that.
Yeah.
Visualization has long been used
to help explain and understand
the subatomic world.
And these pictures have
become more sophisticated
as our understanding
has improved.
The ancient Greeks
believed that matter
could be split in
more and more parts
until, in the end, what was left
were the smallest indivisible
constituents, or atoms,
from the Greek word
atomos, which means indivisible.
At the end of the 19th
century, scientists
learned that matter can be
deconstructed into molecules
comprised of atoms.
However, the choice of the
word atom was premature.
In the 20th century, we learned
atoms can be deconstructed
into electrons and
their nuclei, comprised
of protons and
neutrons, and eventually
that every proton
or neutron contains
three primary quarks that define
their separate identities.
Often, constituent
parts of all matter
are portrayed as being shaped
like round billiard balls,
or in the case of quarks,
as balls within the larger
ball of a proton.
We add squiggly lines,
arrows, and other shapes
to denote the forces at
work at the quantum scale.
While these diagrams can
help explain what's going on,
they in no way
represent the reality
of what this quantum
world is actually like.
Reference image that is
in your slide deck is--
I look at that, and I have no
idea what's going on in there.
I see little balls with
up arrows and down arrows
and squiggly lines.
In the proton, the quarks are
held together by a force where
gluons are exchanged, and with
such a strength that the quarks
and gluons cannot be isolated.
The quarks and gluons carry
a new quantum property
known as color.
The theory used to
describe this force
is known as quantum
chromodynamics, or QCD,
the quantum theory of color.
There are three types
of quantum color,
called red, blue,
and green, in analogy
to the primary colors
of visible light.
All observable systems
of quarks and gluons
and their associated
antiparticles found in nature
are predicted in QCD
to have equal amounts
of red, blue, and green color.
That is, they are colored white,
in analogy to visible light.
Quarks do not actually
have these colors,
but just as white light can be
divided into different colors,
so can quark systems be divided
into equal amounts of red,
green, and blue.
When we enter the
quantum world, particles
that are confined
to small volumes
move at near light speed.
Everything is in
continual motion.
Gluons transform their energy
into pairs of virtual matter
and antimatter that
are continuously
created and destroyed, creating
a quark C, their existence
exerted on other
particles as a pressure.
In this strange quantum
world, conservation of energy
can be temporarily
broken, and even
massive matter-antimatter
pairs can live short times.
Yet, order also rules.
Each elementary particle
has a quantum property
known as spin, which behaves
like an intrinsic angular
momentum.
Nature's rules for spin provide
order to the visible universe,
and is the reason for the
periodic table of the elements
and the shell
structure of nuclei.
To learn about the underlying
structure of matter,
scientists often
rely on microscopes.
In a microscope, light scatters
from the object of interest.
The scattered light
is focused, detected
in the eye of the viewer,
and processed in our brain.
The process is non-destructive,
in that the leaf or insect
is not affected.
With our eyes, we can
readily discern structures
of very large
scales in the cosmos
to human-sized scales of a meter
down to scales of 10 microns,
as, for example, a layer of the
familiar kitchen aluminum foil.
The ratio of such
aluminum foil to a meter
is down by a factor of 100,000.
Scaling down with
another factor of 100,000
gives the size of
an atom, which we
can see with powerful
electron microscopes.
One needs to scale down with
yet another factor of 100,000
to come to the size of a proton,
less than 1 femtometer, or 10
to the minus 15th meters.
To see inside matter
at this tiny scale,
we use electron
accelerators as microscopes.
HERA was a particle
accelerator located at DESY
in Hamburg, Germany,
operating from 1992 to 2007.
HERA was the world's first
and, up to now, only collider
facility of electron
and proton beams,
and discovered that gluons
dominate deep inside a proton.
Jefferson Lab, located in
Newport News, Virginia,
uses intense and
polarized electron
beams to impinge on
fixed targets of protons
and heavier nuclei to make
precise maps of matter
in a region where a
few quarks dominate.
A major new accelerator, the
Electron Ion Collider, or EIC,
is being developed
in the US, to be
located at Brookhaven National
Lab in Long Island, New York.
And it is anticipated to
start operations in the 2030s.
EIC will provide precise maps
to bridge the regions where
a few quarks dominate the
structure of protons and nuclei
to where gluons dominate.
The goal is to provide
us with an understanding
of the internal
structure of the proton
and more complex
atomic nuclei that
is comparable to our
knowledge of the electron
structure of atoms,
which lies at the heart
of modern technologies.
What if there were no gluons
and quark-gluon interactions?
Your mass and the mass
of the visible world
would drop by about
an order of magnitude.
The MRI technique is based on
using a high magnetic field
to reverse the spins of
the protons in the body.
Without gluons and
quark-gluon interactions,
the signal strength would
drop to 20% of its value.
Indeed, without
gluons, there would
be no nucleons, no atomic
nuclei, no visible world.
Is it science fiction
to believe understanding
this miraculous quark-gluon
structure of nuclei
can lead to 21st
century applications?
No, as even if the
internal structure
of protons and more
complex atomic nuclei
reside in a quantum
world with light speeds,
with ever changing
numbers or particles,
and with strong interactions,
ultimate knowledge
of this world will lead to
the future of modern industry
and medical applications.
An example is given by
modern computing that
relies on our
knowledge and ability
to manipulate the quantum world.
How do we learn about
this strange world
with electron accelerators?
Like conventional cameras,
how our accelerator sees
its subject is governed by
two adjustable parameters,
resolution, or pixel
size, and shutter speed.
The resolution is correlated
with the energy of the device.
To probe substructures
of the proton
with its 1 femtometer
size, the electron
must be moving very
near light speed.
The negatively charged
electron interacts
with the fractionally charged
quarks inside the proton
by exchanging a photon,
the quantum of electricity
and magnetism.
This photon exchange can
keep the proton intact,
but more commonly
smashes it in pieces.
Google Earth, in zooming
from the Earth's radius
to the MIT dome, increases
the spatial resolution
by about a factor of
100,000, the same factor
we saw earlier that successively
brings us from a human height
to the thickness of
household aluminum foil,
then to the size of
an atom, and finally
to the radius of a proton.
The shutter of a
camera is a door
that opens for a definite
time to allow selected light
to reach the medium.
This time can, for
our accelerator,
also be determined from the
electron and the proton,
and can be equated with
the value of Bjorken-x.
x can be interpreted
as the fraction
of momentum of the proton that
is carried by the struck quark.
Mostly based on a large
data set from the only
previous electron-proton
collider,
we have accumulated snapshots
of the charged structure
of the proton taken in a special
boosted reference frame, where
1 over x represents the
shutter speed and 1 over q
the spatial resolution.
QCD prescribes an evolution
with q squared, which
connects quarks and gluons.
The animation shows the
quark and gluon momentum
distributions derived
from these data.
Note that the gluon,
g, and C quark,
s, distributions are reduced by
a factor of 20 in these graphs.
In a regular microscope, we use
light to scatter from objects
to magnify such that we
can see them with our eyes.
This light does not disturb
the object, as we see it as is.
This is not true for our high
energy electron scattering
microscope.
As an artifact of
the special reference
frame used for interpretation
of the scattering
experiments smashing
the proton apart,
we have gathered knowledge about
the one-dimensional momentum
fractions of quarks
and gluons inside them.
We have also gathered knowledge
about the transverse spatial
size of the composite proton
from elastic scattering
where the proton stays intact.
This is important
knowledge, but limited.
Due to these
limitations, it has been
difficult to portray the
inner structure and dynamics
of the proton.
But what do the data tell us?
For the first time, we
have constructed animations
to illustrate the proton
structure as a variation
with x and as a
variation with q squared.
If one views deep inside the
proton with fast shutter speeds
or at small values of
Bjorken-x, its structure
is dominated by gluons.
Gluons split in more
gluons, and two gluons
can recombine into one, causing
much activity or dynamics.
Viewed with more
modest shutter speeds,
the process where
a gluon creates
two quarks, one quark and
one anti-quark, can be seen.
Such a fluctuation is the root
of what is termed a quark C,
and is, for example, responsible
for details of the inner charge
distribution of the
charge-neutral neutron.
Viewed at slow shutter
speeds, or at large Bjorken-x,
the proton structure
gets dominated
by three effective blobs,
which carry the valence quark
identity of the proton as
being two up quarks and one
down quark, confined
together in a single proton
by the exchange of gluons.
What do we see when we
peer inside the proton
while increasing the
spatial resolution q
squared of our camera?
The answer depends on at which
shutter speed x we are looking.
At small values of x, we
see more detail appear,
with increasing q squared.
But we also see more
and more gluons appear
due to the specifics of QCD.
The observer will have to
distill this information
from what appears a
squashed pancake-like proton
due to the relativistic effect
called Lorentz contraction.
At medium x, we see again
the details increase,
and both the density of
the gluons and quark C
increase with q squared,
the gluons faster.
At high x, we see a coarse
structure reflecting two up
and one down quarks,
a structure that
becomes more evident at
higher q squared, with also
more gluons and quark C
appearing with q squared,
as driven by QCD.
But again, the squashing
of the spherical proton
into the pancake-like object
complicates the ability
of the observer to
extract the proton's
structure and underlying
quark-gluon interactions.
By varying the pixel
size and the shutter
speed of our electron
accelerator camera,
we have gathered information
about the proton structure
over the last five decades,
since the discovery
of quarks and QCD.
We learned about the
transverse spatial size
of the composite proton and
the one-dimensional momentum
fractions of quarks
and gluons inside them.
However, large gaps of
understanding remain.
For now, we have
used our imagination
to fill this gap and animate
what the data tell us
about the
three-dimensional structure
of the matter deep inside us.
But much better, QCD theory
developments over the last two
decades now provide
the foundation
to extract these
three-dimensional pictures
of the structure from select
designer electron quark
scattering processes.
To accomplish this,
we need a microscope
with sufficient intensity
to capture these designer
processes and image the
structures at the finest
quark-gluon levels to charter
the rapidly moving gluon
oceans, quark C, and
primary quark continents.
The residue of the
quark gluon interactions
in individual
protons and neutrons
leaks out and creates
sufficient nuclear binding
to pack protons and
neutrons tightly together
in tiny atomic nuclei.
These act well beyond a
mere collection of protons
and neutrons, and are
much more dynamic,
harboring mysteries
as tell-tales
of the underlying
quark-gluon world.
And vice versa, the behavior
of quarks and gluons
is expected to be entangled
with the structure
of the nucleus they reside in.
Massive computer
simulations indicate
exotic gluons may be exchanged
between individual protons
and neutrons.
The nucleus can also
act as an amplifier
and pack so many gluons
together that no more fit,
leading to saturation
of the interactions.
For the first time,
we have developed
a new animation-based
framework in which
to communicate,
understand and explore
the fundamental structure of
matter for the curious mind.
These first-generation
animations
are based on current
understanding
and available data,
and seek to capture
essential aspects of the
strange and beautiful quantum
world of the microcosm.
But many mysteries remain
in how the visible matter
in the universe is constructed
from elementary constituents.
We now are working
on a 3D visualization
of these animations,
and then we'll
continue our journey
to animate the nucleus.